hola que tal veamos si podemos abordar
un nuevo problema de cómo obtener la
gráfica de una hipérbola pero un poco
más complicado donde la función es x
menos 1 al cuadrado sobre 16 sobre 16
menos y más 1
todo esto al cuadrado sobre 4 sobre 4
igual a 1 así que la primera cosa que
podemos reconocer es que debe quedar
claro es que la ecuación de una
hipérbola que hemos estado trabajando
desde vídeos previos donde a diferencia
de la elipse tenemos un menos afectando
nuestro segundo término así que también
puedes identificar qué tipo de sección
de cónica es y como segundo paso sería
identificar cuál es su gráfica así que
aquí tenemos la ecuación de una
hipérbola como lo habíamos dicho y
espero ya no haya problemas con ella y
una forma fácil como habíamos dicho de
reconocer es por el menos que está
afectando a la aie cuadrada y de hecho
nosotros podemos cambiarlo y obtener la
clásica ecuación
rizada de la hipérbola y tenemos por
aquí que sería x cuadrada sobre 16 - ye
cuadradas sobre 4 igual a 1 y todo esto
para obtener una facilidad mayor de como
entender las cosas y bien acabo de
escribir como sabemos esta área centrada
en el 0 0 y éstas tendrían en común las
mismas así en total sólo que esta
segunda bueno esta primera que
escribimos estaría centrada en el 1,21
donde vendría siendo x igual a 1 e igual
a menos 1 y la forma de pensar esto es
que si x es igual a 1 es para que dicho
término se convierta en 0 y por eso es
parte del centro y lo mismo para allí
igual a menos uno hace todo el dicho
término igual a cero y aquí por supuesto
el centro es el origen el centro es el 0
0 una forma sencilla de graficar esto es
graficando primero la estandarizada y
luego viendo que cambia para cuando
nuestro centro es el 1 - 1 así que
hagamos esto vamos a figurar nos cuál
sería la pendiente de dichas a sin total
y luego
enviarla o adaptarla para nuestra otra
ecuación entonces si vamos con esta
resolvamos x ya que es como siempre se
empieza y entonces tendríamos lo
siguiente a la hora de restar de ambas
partes de la ecuación x cuadrada sobre
16 nos queda de este lado al menos 10
cuadrada sobre 4 igual a menos x
cuadradas sobre 16 más 1 y trabajando
sobre esta hipérbola vamos a ahora a
multiplicar ambos lados de nuestra
ecuación x menos 4 y luego entonces
tendríamos que esto es igual a 10
cuadrada igual a al menos 4 por el menos
x cuadradas que sé que algo positivo
entonces es x cuadradas sobre 44 entre
16 nos queda un cuarto menos 4 y
entonces ahora si es igual a más menos
la raíz cuadrada de ese término de x
cuadrada sobre 4 menos 4 así que ahora
para figurar nos lajas into estás sólo
tendríamos que pensar qué pasaría si x
se aproxima a más infinito oa menos
infinito
si x toma un valor muy grande
positivamente o muy grande negativamente
y dicho análisis lo hemos hecho
demasiadas veces anteriormente y yo creo
que sea importante ahora ver cómo se
comportaría dicha fórmula y no es
importante memorizarlo pues siempre va a
cambiar así que ahora por nuestra
intuición veamos qué dice la ecuación
que nos puede decir cuando x se aproxima
a más menos infinito la función o cómo
se va a poder comportar nuestra gráfica
entonces ya se estaría aproximando en
este caso una vez más podemos observar
que este término va a dominar dicha
función que esté menos 4 cuando tomemos
valores muy muy grandes positivos o
negativos este valor en realidad no
mueve tanto a nuestra función por lo que
entonces podríamos decir que conforme
nos estamos aproximando a infinito o
menos infinito va a ser aproximadamente
más menos la raíz cuadrada de x cuadrada
sobre 4 y al calcular la raíz de esto es
más
x sobre 2 así que hagámoslo si dibujamos
nuestras asín todas estas as in total
estarán representadas de la siguiente
forma recuerda que esto que acabamos de
hacer es justo para encontrarlas
entonces ahora por supuesto tendríamos
que ver más adelante como serían para
cuando el centro es igual a 1 - 1 así
que voy a dibujar dichas líneas pero
bueno en realidad los síntomas no
cambiarían simplemente está como
recorriendo el centro de dicha hipérbola
así que aquí tenemos nuestro eje de
leyes y por acá estará nuestro eje de
las x
luego entonces busquemos el centro uno
menos uno y por aquí tenemos el uno que
avanzamos y el menos uno nuestro centro
de dicha hipérbola estaría por aquí así
que nuestro resultado obtenido
tendríamos más o menos un medio así que
lleguemos a la parte positiva y lo que
significa para cuando tenemos dos
unidades hacia la derecha en realidad
nos estaríamos moviendo una dada la
gráfica no entonces ésta será la primera
tendremos una dos unidades que sería en
este punto de por aquí y nuestra sin
total atravesaría por acá pero vamos a
extenderla para que sea más gráfico
y luego entonces si trazamos nuestras
into está negativa la de pendiente
negativa veamos también en dónde se
sitúa el centro uno menos uno y respecto
a esto vamos a trazar nuestro punto de
la asín total y la veríamos reflejada
por este lado de acá entonces como es
pendiente negativa se va hacia la
izquierda y también la vamos a extender
un poco para que se vea más gráfico esto
y en fin estas son nuestras y en total
ya para nuestro centro 1 coma menos 1
bueno y ahora que tenemos nuestras a
síntomas de la hipérbola la pregunta
sería será una hipérbola vertical u
horizontal y una forma sencilla de ver
esto bueno en realidad existen dos
formas de ver esto si solo vemos la
ecuación de aquí cuando tomamos la raíz
positiva este va a ser ligeramente por
debajo de la a sin total la cinta es
esto de por aquí bueno lo que me quiero
referir es que este menos 4 va a abarcar
diferencia para cuando estemos
ligeramente por arriba de la 5ta o
ligeramente por abajo de nuestra así
dependiendo de la raíz que tomemos pero
bueno lo que me dice mi intuición sería
que vamos a estar un poco por debajo de
la raíz negativa pero en realidad lo que
voy a hacer es checarlo de la otra
manera y lo haré como en el último vídeo
que pasa para cuando este término es
cero este término de por aquí
para cuando x es igual a 1
eso puede siempre pasar pues x1 si x es
igual a 1 aquí dicho término se hace
cero y luego tenemos la situación para
cuando x es igual a 1 y esto es
seguramente 0 entonces vamos a tener
menos de uno bueno ye más un al cuadrado
pero ese término en realidad es negativo
por lo que x no va a ser igual a 1 pues
no podemos tener el término negativo
pero ahora veamos el otro caso que pasa
para cuando llegue es igual a menos 1 y
se nos hace este segundo término
aquí vemos que nos queda el término al
primer término de las equis positivo por
lo tanto jesse puede ser igual a menos 1
entonces nos quedaría x menos 1 al
cuadrado sobre 16 igual a uno
simplemente cancelamos el segundo
término y luego podríamos multiplicar
ambos lados por 16 tendríamos esto de
aquí x menos 1 al cuadrado sobre 16
igual a 1 multiplicamos ambos lados por
16 lo que vamos a ir haciendo es ir
simplificando nuestra ecuación y al
multiplicar por 16 tenemos x menos 1 al
cuadrado igual a 16 y luego podemos
sacar la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados
tendríamos x menos 1 igual a más menos 4
luego entonces si x es igual a más 4
entonces al despejar el 1 sumarle de
ambos lados uno tenemos que x es igual a
5 y luego para el otro caso si x es
igual a 4 le restamos 1 tenemos que x es
igual a 3 y entonces veamos en la
gráfica donde se situaría dicho punto
serán los puntos 5 menos 1 y el 31
entonces al buscarlos por aquí
tendríamos 5 coma menos 1
el 331 pero espere un momento no
expliquen y no de acá más bien están
bien mis puntos pero una parte puede ser
x igual a más 4 o x igual a menos 4 para
cuando x es igual a 4 y despejó bueno
sumo de ambas partes el 1 entonces nos
queda que x es igual a 5 pero para el
caso en el que x es igual a menos 4 y le
sumamos 1 entonces nos queda x menos 3 y
entonces ese otro punto se sitúa por acá
así que estos dos puntos están
representando parte de nuestra hipérbola
y entonces nuestra intuición es correcta
ahora lo que pasa es lo que comenté esto
va a ser cierto un poco por debajo para
la raíz positiva y queda por debajo de
la cinta está entonces obtenemos una
curva que luce algo así y luego por acá
es exactamente lo mismo quedamos muy
cercanos a la 5ta
de esta forma mi hipérbola y por
supuesto nuestras asín totales se
mantienen por siempre y si quieres
puedes intentarlo con otros puntos para
afirmar lo que acabamos de comentar la
parte complicada de esto en realidad es
identificarlas a síntomas y lograr
observadas y es una hipérbola horizontal
o una hipérbola vertical así que nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo